i
ah
la canciller alemana angela merkel
reconoció que hay ansias de reapertura
en alemania en especial después de dos
meses de restricciones estrictas y un
paso concreto hacia la reapertura se dio
esta semana con el regreso a clases en
la mayoría de las regiones de alemania y
en particular para los alumnos más
jóvenes en escuelas de primaria o en
guarderías el regreso se da por supuesto
bajo estrictas medidas de higiene con
medidas como la reducción en el número
de alumnos por clase o la rotación entre
la virtualidad y la presencialidad para
así evitar al máximo los posibles
contactos también se le dará más
prioridad la vacunación de los
profesores aunque algunos ven este
regreso a clases con escepticismo pues
consideran que puede llevar a que
aumenten las infecciones de nuevo la
mayoría de los alemanes apoyan este
regreso progresivo a la presencialidad y
de hecho según una encuesta de mediados
de este mes el 58% de los alemanes ve
esta medida con buenos ojos
[Música]
más de un millón de estudiantes de
distintos ciclos se encuentran en la
incertidumbre sobre el inicio oficial de
las clases que según el ministerio de
educación y cultura está previsto para
el próximo martes 2 de marzo aquí en
paraguay sin embargo los principales
gremios docentes del país anunciaron
para ese mismo día una serie de
movilizaciones y protestas a nivel
nacional debido principalmente a dos
razones la número uno es que según dicen
no están garantizadas las condiciones
que aseguren la salud del cuerpo docente
ni de los estudiantes y además más de
400 establecimientos escolares no
estarían en condiciones edilicias para
poder ingresar a esos lugares así que la
situación aquí es de incertidumbre y
sabremos cuál va a ser la situación la
próxima semana
[Música]
después de una notable reducción en el
número de casos diarios de kobe 19
sudáfrica ha reabierto los colegios y
esto se da después de varias semanas de
que la reapertura se hubiera postergado
dado que el país se encontraba en plena
segunda ola de la pandemia
sudáfrica es un país que ha perdido más
de mil maestros en el último año y por
eso en esta ocasión se ha hecho especial
énfasis en que la reapertura cuente con
las medidas de bioseguridad adecuadas
sin embargo un estudio a nivel nacional
ha determinado que menos del 40 por
ciento de las escuelas se encuentran
preparadas para esta reapertura y muchas
de ellas alegan que no cuentan con los
equipos de protección necesarios para
reactivar plenamente sus actividades por
otra parte el sistema educativo enfrenta
también un problema adicional y es el
desafío que van a tener miles de
estudiantes que dados los cierres han
tenido retrasos en muy grandes en el
currículum académico y esto afecta sobre
todo a aquellos estudiantes que no
cuentan con la tecnología o los medios
necesarios para la educación virtual
[Música]